donc madame la ministre en avril dernier
un collègue élisabeth doineau sénatrice
de la mayenne et le maire de blain
jean-michel buffles ont saisi le premier
ministre autour du dossier de la liaison
routière entre saint nazaire et laval il
a même été créé il ya plusieurs années
une association regroupant les élus les
acteurs de la vie économique et les
trois départements de loire-atlantique
mayenne maine et loire pour faire
aboutir ce dossier
certaines études ont été menées en
mayenne notamment en ce qui concerne le
contournement de cossé-le-vivien
également dans le maine et loire pour
point c'est sûr le château bruyant et
treffieux pour la loire atlantique sur
la partie de la route nationale rn 171
de nausée à saint nazaire l'état a
concentré ses investissements sur la
section entre savenay et le futur contre
le mans contournement debout vont
laissant l'autre son de notables sans
nouvelles perspectives
pourtant la sortie de là deux voix deux
fois deux voies rennes nantes vers la
grigonnais particulièrement dangereuse à
travers cette blanc n'est plus
supportable pour les habitants de cette
commune est un contenant de l'avenue
absolument nécessaire la commune de
blain est aujourd'hui traversée par
treize mille véhicules par jour avec la
avec la kz également avec redon et un
petit problème de feuilles le nombre
s'élève à 23 mille véhicules par jour
avec une projection de 31 mille
véhicules dans les dix ans à venir
plusieurs alternatives ont été étudiées
entre la rn 137 rn171 bouvron et puis
également entre la rn 173 et la rn171 au
sud de blain pour autant cette dernière
alternative ne permettra pas un
aménagement complet du contournement de
blain il faut donc impérativement un
aménagement de la rn 171 intégrant
pleinement le contournement de la ville
cinq possibilités d'aménagement un
contournement ont été récemment dévoilée
concernant cette rn 171 aussi madame la
ministre
pouvez-vous nous informer des dernières
positions du comité consultatif piloté
par la préfecture de loire atlantique
à la lumière de l'abandon notamment du
projet du nouvel aéroport à notre dame
des landes et donc de la desserte
routière dédié qui était prévu lors de
la construction de cet aéroport notât
merci merci la parole est à madame
elisabeth board ministre chargé des
transports
madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur priou vous souhaitez connaître
ma position relative à l'aménagement de
la rn 171 en particulier au niveau de la
commune de blain l'état a engagé une
étude de faisabilité sur la liaison
entre la rn 171 à bouvron et la rn 137
han co-maîtrise d'ouvragé avec le
conseil départemental de loire
atlantique afin notamment d'assurer une
bonne coordination entre les travaux en
cours sur le réseau routier national et
les aménagements étudiée par le conseil
départemental sur le secteur cette
démarche a permis d'établir un état des
lieux de la rn 171 et des axes assurant
la liaison entre nort sur erdre
éprouveront vous le savez la décision
d'abandon du projet d'aéroport à notre
dame des landes est venue modifier le
cadre général de cette réflexion et a
nécessité de réinterroger l'ensemble des
hypothèses et des résultats des études
de trafic mené jusqu alors un temps
d'étude supplémentaire a donc été
nécessaires pour prendre en compte ces
nouvelles vies potez les études
complémentaires ont fait l'objet d'une
restitution au cours d'un comité de
suivi le 5 juillet auxquels vous étiez
convié ce comité après permis de
présenter les résultats des diagnostics
réalisés ainsi que les cinq scénarios
d'aménagement étudié deux de ces
scénarios consiste à aménager la rn 171
ans prévoyant notamment un contournement
complet de blain tandis que les autres
prévoient d'aménager une liaison est
ouest
en parallèle des rd 16 et rd 164
existants une phase de concertation avec
le public est prévue au cours de l'année
2019 pour déterminer le parti
d'aménagement préférentiel en s'appuyant
sur les études menées votre au point de
vue sera naturellement examiné et pris
en compte
à cette occasion je ne manquerai pas de
revenir vers vous à l'issue de cette
concertation pour vous informer des
suites que nous donnerons sur
l'aménagement de cet axe essentiel au
bon développement de la loire atlantique
or l'état monsieur prix ou pour répondre
à madame la ministre
merci madame la ministre est bien
évident que ce contournement est attendu
et doit s'inscrire dans le projet
stratégique pour les
8 et du grand ouest on a souvent
l'occasion en commission de rappeler les
conséquences de l'abandon par le
gouvernement du futur aéroport de notre
dame des landes donc il nous faudra des
mesures compensatoires extrêmement forte
sur ce dossier là comme sur d'autres et
qu'il s'inscrive dans le contrat
d'avenir promis par l'état à l'occasion
de cet abandon
merci